this is a male tree pangolin he is six
months old
critically endangered and
under-researched the tree pangolin is a
mammalian species like no other found
throughout asia and africa pangolins can
be traced back 66 million years meaning
they lived amongst dinosaurs
they're the only mammals on earth
covered in scales which account for
about 20 of their body weight
these large protective scales are made
of keratin
the same thing human nails and hair are
made from
tree pangolins use their long claws to
climb on trees and branches in an
endless search for prey baby penguins
like the one here get around by riding
their mother's tails
though they have poor eyesight and
hearing their strong sense of smell and
elastic tongue allows them to catch a
meal of mostly ants and termites
when the pangolin senses danger it will
curl up into a ball making it almost
invincible in the wild
humans however are a dangerous threat
the pangolin scales are thought to have
healing properties though there's no
science to back that up
because of that pangolins are the most
heavily trafficked mammals in the world
worth almost three hundred dollars per
pound on the black market
no one knows how many pangolins are left
but we do know that their number is
shrinking fast
this is the tree penguin
[Music]
you